I'm about to start the biggest
transformation of my life this soldier
is the scariest thing I've ever done but
I mean through the skinnier person
inside of me chair guy shirt sleeve back
in may 9 2015 4 15 1975 and then always
everything she slowly start losing
weight and well the reason she got thing
every sleeve is cuz she was out plateau
she could zoom away so then she got
again sleep well then it came to a point
where he has sepia yeah
because she'd come at another plateau
with the gastric Stephen wasn't losing
any more weight yeah so then as that
sort of happened in her stomach started
looking gross and I was hanging from my
where she lost so much weight and her
arms and her chin cuz she got like her
stomach removed and her toes yeah right
she loves me awesome cuz she got
everybody's them yeah well the beautiful
thing is well she got him from 44 long
to 36 tough 36 up that's that new piece
already set up but the cool thing what
the but the cool thing is you get to see
her transformation not only from a
physical standpoint but you also get to
see her change here you know from a
mental standpoint no I'm a Jew from not
too hot Wow amazing
oh my god how many pounds has she lost
her you want me to tell you why you want
me to tell you you have to watch the
show I can tell me yeah you have to
watch the show everybody tuned in to
watch the show
you